des habitants obligés de quitter leur
immeuble dans la précipitation après l'
incendie qui a ravagé le sous sol de ce
bâtiment au coeur du quartier
clair-soleil au début de la nuit une
urgence prise en charge par la ville de
besançon depuis 6 heures ce matin là
l'immédiat pour nous c'était d'abord de
mettre les gens à l'abri donc la ville a
ouvert la crèche de clair soleil qui est
juste à côté à la demande des pompiers
on a mobilisé aussi la mjc donc le
centre martin luther king donc on a
accueilli les gens les mettre à l'abri
et ensuite trouver des solutions de
relogement
quand on a vu que les suites de la 110
empêcherait toute façon d'habiter ce
soir dans leur appartement
un incendie d'origine criminelle dont
les traces extérieures sont peu visibles
qui a littéralement ravagé le parking
souterrain et les dizaines de véhicules
qu'il contenait certains habitants
choqués semblait encore désemparé et
sans réelle information après le
sinistre parti aux hôtels il m'a dit
c'est partir au tel quel hôtel je sais
pas et attendre que attendait jusqu'à un
peu plus tard on vous voit renseigner
les gens sur leur situation
on vous a mandaté pour ça ou le fait
bénévolement
moi je suis habitants ici et puis vint
solidarité s'organise
on est un peu abandonnés parce qu'on a
personne pour nous orienter
actuellement la municipalité qui prévoit
une réunion d'information cet après midi
pour trouver une solution d'hébergement
à tous les sinistrés